شكله مرعب ومخيف وصوته اشبه بصوت وحش
مفترس حجم ضخم وريش اسود خشن وثلاثه خناجر
حاده زرعت في قدميه ضربه واحده منها تعني
الموت المحتم انه طائر الكاسواري او
الشبنم اخطر طائر على وجه الارض
[موسيقى]
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
بعرفه الكبير وريشه الاسود وحجمه الضغط قد
يحسب البعض طائر الشاب نم ديناصورا كتبت
له النجاه من الانقراض او ربما وحشا من
الوحوش الاسطوريه
وزن الشاب لم يصل الى 75 كيلو جراما وطوله
قد يقارب المترين ويعتبر ثاني اضخم الطيور
على وجه الارض بعض النعام والان ولديه
ثلاثه مخالب حاده وطويله كالخناجر يبلغ
طول الواحد منها عشره سنتيمترات وهي اقوى
مخالب لطائر على وجه الارض
للوهله الاولى يبدو الشاب نمخجولا ومسالما
مع البشر الا ان مضايقته قد تترتب عليها
عواقب وخيمه فهو متقلب المزاج وسرعان ما
يتحول الى وحش مفترس وقاتل متسلسل حين
يعتريه الغضب ورغم انه لا يستطيع الطيران
الا انه عداء سريع وماهر
وبمخالبه الحاده يستطيع استخراج احشاء
غريمه وحسب موسوعه غينيس للارقام القياسيه
تعتبر الطيور الشبنام اخطر طيور العالم اذ
انها تقدر على القتل بمجرد ضربه واحده
سريعه ومباغته عام 2019 قتل شابنا رجلا في
ولايه فلوريد الامريكيه وهنا يطارد الحراس
بشكل جنوني
رغم ان هذا الطائر خجول جدا وقت سلمه الا
انه عند تعرضه لاي هجوم يصبح الاكثر شراسه
فمخالبه الثلاثه التي يبلغ طول الواحد
منها 10 سم مرعبه ويستطيع من خلالها نسع
احشاء اي مهاجم
ينتشر الشابنا بكثره في غينيا الجديده وهي
موطنه الاصلي الى جانب غابات استراليا
ايضا ورغم كل صفاته المرعبه رجحت دراسه
حديثه انه كان اول طائر استانسه الانسان
قبل الاف السنين
السكان عند اصطيادهم لطائر الشابلنم
يعتمدون على ما يعرف بالبصمه اي ان هذا
الطائر لحظه ولادته يتعلق باول كائن يراه
لذا تتم تربيته حتى السن صغيره ثم يصبح
وجبه لدى بعض السكان لكن الخطر الاكبر عند
بلوغه وقتها من الصعب التعامل معه نظرا
لعدوانيته المحتمله
اليوم يواجه الشاب نام خطر الانقراض فهو
صيد مفضل لدى اصحاب مصانع الزينه والملابس
وريشه وعظامه تعتبر مواده ثمينه جدا
بالاضافه الى ان لحمه طعام مفضل لسكان
جزيره غينيا الجديده وفي بعض الثقافات يتم
اصطياده حيا لتقديمه كمهر للزواج فمن يريد
الظفر بفتاه احلامه ربما عليه المخاطره
بحياته ليتمكن من اهدائها اخطر طائر في
العالم
[موسيقى]